you've maybe seen the skinny girl shot
here on Tick Tock do this one today and
you will get snatched please don't do
that do not do this once a day or like
ever
to combine water
two teaspoons of cayenne pepper holy two
teaspoons of turmeric and a little bit
of pepper plus some honey to taste all I
have to do is drink maple syrup lemon
juice cayenne pepper and water I'm sorry
do you want to shoot yourself all day or
like dissolve the teeth right out of
your mouth because that's the most
likely outcome of a drink like this
you're shaking are you all right just
leave me alone yes it's true the apple
cider vinegar has been shown to help
reduce
response reduce appetite and therefore
help to support weight loss but it's
also been suggested that one of the ways
it helps reduce your appetite is by
making you so nauseous that you don't
actually want to eat combination of
straight up acid and the capsaicin in
the Cayenne is literal Napalm for your
bowels so sure you'd be losing some
weight but it would be because you're
like yourself all day I look amazing I'm
not really sure what the point of
looking snatched is when you can't even
leave the house out of fear of having an
accident please don't do this please
don't